okay I mentioned on Tuesday that we have
a four thousand dollar matching grant
challenge for the david pakman show
fundraiser you can check this out at
david pakman.com slash donate yeah long
time supporter of the david packard show
who's choosing to remain anonymous has
said that he will match dollar for
dollar the next four thousand dollars in
donations the time limit is midnight
Eastern on Friday January sixth we have
received about uh twelve or thirteen
hundred dollars so far of that four
thousand meaning that there's about
twenty eight hundred dollars of
matchable money ready to go of course
the campaign seeks to create a new
position called the progressive
engagement coordinator to organize and
coordinate progressive action on issues
and candidates that matter we're also
going to be doing out what what I hope
will be the last major upgrade to the
david pakman show studio in a while we
are going to actually have a
professional sort of set created here in
the studio we already have the designs
it's all ready to go we now just have to
raise the money for it and a whole bunch
of other stuff including bringing the
show to Amazon Prime that's the goal of
the campaign you can read all about it
at david pakman.com slash donate but the
real urgent and key thing now is four
thousand dollars in matching funds if
you donate twenty dollars 20 times to
write 40 that will actually bring in
forty dollars to the david pakman show
if you donate a hundred dollars the
hundred dollars will be matched with
another hundred and you will actually be
creating a two-hundred-dollar inflow to
the campaign so please please please go
to david pakman.com slash donate any
donation very much appreciated i will
have an update for you uh after the
weekend probably on the monday show